la cybersécurité se trouve au coeur des
activités d'atos
l'entreprise dispose d'un datacenter aux
clayes-sous-bois le but de l'acteur du
numérique protéger les données des
entreprises et collectivités face à des
menaces informatiques de plus en plus
évoluer les moyens mis en oeuvre par les
pirates et par les hackers sont de plus
en plus important et puis il ya une
globalisation de cette connaissance là
si on veut pouvoir se protéger il faut
utiliser les meilleurs outils avec les
meilleures équipes qui ont ses
compétences et ses connaissances
pour se faire atos propose des produits
des logiciels par exemple permettent de
protéger l'identité les communications
ou encore encoder les données d'autres
services sont proposés
on va pouvoir gérer pour le compte d'une
entreprise l'intégralité de son
patrimoine de données on va pouvoir
gérer aussi ce qu'on appelle ses centres
opérationnels de sécurité c'est-à-dire
lui apporter un système de bouclier de
protection face aux attaques cyber dont
elle peut être victime
aujourd'hui le domaine manque de
compétences en europe c'est un manque de
300 mille experts en cybersécurité qui a
été recensé pour pallier cette
problématique l'entreprise s'associe à
des universitaires et des laboratoires
de recherche
on va par exemple dans nos produits
intégrés des recherches et
développements qui sont faits par des
universitaires ou par des laboratoires
de recherche ou d'éco conception que
l'on fait avec nos clients
en fait avec ça on va gagner en
efficacité en vitesse
et puis on va adapter nos solutions
directement au cas des usages clients
une école dédiée à la cybersécurité où
ira à saint quentin en yvelines en
septembre prochain selon lan si le
nombre de cyber attaques a été
multipliée par 4 en 2020